it's just over a year since Argentina
lifted the men's World Cup in Qatar the
country is now getting ready to host
Asia's biggest International football
tournament China had been due to host
this edition of the Asian cup but pulled
out in 2022 due to its zero co9 policy
and Qatar as World Cup hosts in waiting
at that time were in the perfect
position to step up at short notice was
a part of our Legacy to keep using these
venues and the state as well one qar is
becoming now like a half four sport so
always will be keep using in and hosting
these big event so to always be part of
our Legacy it's not only the stadium
it's the stadium and all the facilities
around it Palestine will be making their
third consecutive appearance at the
finals a team determined to be a focal
point of positivity for their people
they're also uh aiming to win their
first ever game uh at this tournament
the cat are the hosts they are a team
with a point to prove they are the
reigning Champions having won this title
in 2019 in the United Arab Emirates but
they failed to replicate that form on
the world stage their World Cup campaign
in 2022 beginning with high expectations
it ended with three straight defeats
since then they have fired two national
coaches Spain's Tintin Marquez the man
who will be in charged for this
tournament somebody with experience of
working at katar's National Aspire
Academy also um in katar's domestic
league but he's had a very limited
amount of time with this squad their
efforts to retain the title begin on
Friday at lucel Stadium the venue where
Argentina beat France in that World Cup
final this time it's katar versus
Lebanon the first of 51 matches coming
your way in this 18th edition of the
Asian cup Andy Richardson Al jazer
Doha make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer